لا الذاكره
مخادعه
تحفظ في ذهنك ما تريد وتنسيك ما تريد
وبالتالي
يتحكم ايضا خبرات العاطفيه والذهنيه عند
الانسان
ترتبط اوقات يعني علاقته بالفنون الادب
بمراحل حياته السعيده والحزينه والمفرحه
المتفائله ايضا الكئيبه والمنهزمه
ومنها هنا يبني مفهومه للزمن الجميل
يعني في كل زمن في كل تقريبا الجميل ايضا
الفاسد
الجميل الجميل هو القبيح هو وجه اخر من
جميل مقبول لكن ايضا يوجد الفاسد وتوجد
الاخطاء موجوده في كل فتره يعني لكن ذاكره
تسمح لك فقط ان تنظر الى ما تريد ان تذكره
وهو الجميل فقط وبالتالي عندما تواجه في
فتره المعاصره كل الانواع المختلفه تتوقع
انه الماضي هو الافضل بينما انت تتذكر
الافضل من الماضي فقط وفي المساله يعني
ذهنيه نفسيه ترتبط بمجتمع معين واللي
موجوده في كل المجتمعات يعني مساله الحنين
موجود في كل المجتمعات يعني انه انه
الانسان سفار وبالتالي لما يسافر ينقل معه
ما يهمه ما له علاقه بتقدم امه او تاخرها
او ثقافه مجتمع او مدري ايش يعني ولا لا
هناك تلازم بين ما نسميه حنا ثقافات
الشعوب وحضارات الشعوب ثقافات في الغالب
في الغالب هي تكون مرتبطه بالجانب المعنوي
الحضارات مرتبطه بالجوانب الماديه
وبالتالي
توهمنا انه في توازي بينهم لكن هناك ممكن
تاخر او مسارات مختلفه ثقافه مسارها دائ
ري وليس خط طولي
العكس الحضاره الحضاره تتغير الصناعات
والتقنيات تتبدل ممكن تقف فجاه صناعه
وياتي بدالها تقنيه لكن الثقافات لا هي
عمليه فرز للعناصر في كل فتره تفرز
العناصر فيها عناصر يستفاد منها في هذا
العصر بينما في عصر اخر